Elvis was very spiritual.
He believed that he had a certain connection with God; not so much more than anybody else did.
But in his search, he was trying to get close to God, so he felt that by helping others,...
...maybe that was his mission.
We got to Vegas and one of the girls in the group, Sylvia,...
...has had a health problem. She has had the test but left before the results.
And when she got to Las Vegas...
...there were urgent emergency calls from her doctors...
...to get in touch with them as soon as possible.
And then her test had come back with a problem...
...and so there was some talk that she has had cancer.
So after the show, we're all down and Elvis comes over...
...as he did every night to address everyone and say good night.
And we're down and he asked "Yes, why?"
We explained to him what the problem was...
...so he took us, the three of us, and we went to the dressing area of our dressing room...
...and he said let's pray.
And as he prayed he touched Sylvia's stomach and he asked God to move whatever it was.
"Just take it away." And the next morning when...
...Sylvia reported to Sunrise Hospital there in Las Vegas...
...they did the test and it was gone.
Whatever it was, whether it was a misdiagnosis...
...or whether God had healed Sylvia through Elvis' faith and our faith, I don't know.
But we believed and Elvis believed also that God had brought a miracle through him.